for people in parts of the US this
Christmas is beginning to look a lot
like their coldest in decades more than
90 million in at least 37 states have
been warned off severe winter weather
the Arctic blast began in the Pacific
Northwest and has swept East causing
temperatures to plunge across the U.S
and Canada the wintry conditions and
freezing roads have brought travel chaos
and also misery for many stranded at
airports at the start of the busiest
travel time of the year
checked our flight you know five this
morning and headed to the airport and
then when we got here we found it was
canceled tired stressed hungry
just hopeless honestly
about 80 percent of the US is set to
experience Sub-Zero temperatures
including places as far south as Texas
the governors of Kentucky and North
Carolina have declared states of
emergency
and while people in some areas are used
to conditions like these many have never
seen such extremely cold weather in a
long time I think in my seven and a half
years living in the Pacific Northwest
and and specifically here in monologue
County area I don't remember a specific
instance where I can remember
temperatures quite this low as the storm
develops it's set to become what U.S
meteorologists call a bomb Cyclone
that's when a system intensifies rapidly
with its central air pressure dropping
at least 24 millibars in 24 hours that
would put it in line with the pressure
of a category three hurricane and bring
about blizzards as well as severe
thunderstorms and whiteout conditions
the once in a generation winter weather
event is threatening to deliver the
coldest Christmas to the Midwest in
nearly 40 years and it may not be so
long until the next one U.S scientists
say climate change has made storms like
this increasing frequency and intensity
during the past 70 years caroleg Al
Jazeera